damals zog herzlich willkommen wie heute
meine lieben freunde zu einem neuen
video nicht mit mir rein sondern genau
wir haben hier zwischen uns ein
glücksrad stehen wenn ihr lieben freunde
die ihr seht schon was ihr drauf steht
beispielsweise mario tun für schinken
frikadellen mike rodgers damit besonders
lecker gold cup mein favourit bestellt
immer somit exakt ermitteln wir stellen
mit wodka und oliven wollen wohl die
polka kapitza schreiben die bewertungen
ich habe uns eine selbst erfüllen
das habe ich auf jeden fall gekauft ich
glaube so eine pizza kit gekauft da drin
ist quasi zeigt den mann dann schon gar
nicht mehr machen muss dann habe ich zu
machen soße gekauft diese ware auch noch
drin und jetzt habe ich auch noch
gekauft also das sind quasi unsere
grundlegenden daten und ob dreht sich
jeder vier verschiedene dienste
[Musik]
und wenn überhaupt zu bekommen blieben
ok über die leben kann ich gut leben ich
hab so lieben ja das wie gesagt habe ich
ja damals auseinandersetzung mit denen
vor zehn jahren ungeschlagen
ich habe die geschlagen würdest du hast
du richtig die weil die habe ich
zurückgeschlagen
ok max erstes ist oliven das heißt ich
schreibe ich hier mal max hin und
streiche oliven durch das heißt ich sehe
es zum ersten mal wurde damit auf die
situation weiter machen ja ja oft mit
april dieses jahres
[Musik]
auch gut mal und oliven also es sich
jeden morgen flüchter von abends es ist
immer auf zeit bestellt muss die man mit
in den ofen oder kein tier am ende drauf
machen die male mussten die nase stopfen
[Musik]
der löcher und apfel und wünsche mir ich
wünsche mir tut weh meinte liebe ist
okay das geht klar was er weiß und
lieben klang aus mit den kaka aber kommt
drauf an wie man sie mit integriert aber
er ist hätte ich es hätte uns bei der ex
trainer von boca bordkarten könnte mit
chips ich bin ich bin halt ein bisschen
erkältet wenn ich jetzt noch besser als
er dann bin ich wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen das ist ja nun jobs könnte das
auf der pizza es gibt somit bösen so new
york pizza und so gibt somit bisschen
brauchen weil die lieben börsen in new
york dass ich meine das ernst nimmt so
petzold und so das ist jetzt hallo
mclaren geführt es gab ja damals nicht
hot dogs oder doch wenn ich jetzt tue
ich bekomme ich werde diese pizza
bringen ließen
[Musik]
wir haben überhaupt nicht würde ich mir
davon konnte auch vertritt die meinung
asse wenn man die am ende drauf ich das
würde gerne pizza hut moment einfach
lecker
bekannt
exane auch okay sein
das hier ist die pizza box bisschen der
pizzateig und dafür zieht tomatensoße
drin ist also dass hier kommt auf jeden
fall schon mal bei uns beiden auf die
pizza drauf und dafür sind dann meine
toppings nämlich einmal vegetarische
menü plastik tabelle dann minimal
köpfchen und bissen den ketchup und da
denkt sich so ein schönes dorf mich
drauf können wir denken das ist so eine
kindergeburtstags pizza weist die waren
da das fußballspiel und nachher machen
die alle selbst fit sein sohn dann
packen die ganzen jungs sich in gewissen
und catcher brauche aber der apfel
deshalb jetzt ein bisschen ihren los wir
dürfen jetzt nicht wieder falsch machen
hier ist alles meine hand gehabt ich
habe dafür nicht falsch gemacht ja ich
hab das komplett zusammen geknetet hat
sich der pizzabäcker aber man muss es
wirklich einfach so was schon wieder
falsch jetzt richtig muss einfach voraus
ich habe keine arbeit gegessen habt seid
ihr so lecker ich direkt gestern könnt
ihr euch kaufen wollte gibt es über alle
politiker und volk will merkt man ihren
hunger dann kandidiert oder der akademie
ist eine zusatzfunktion wir mit
eingebauten wir das produkt bindung zu
fördern packung mit pizza bestellen den
teig zusammen mit dem backpapier auf dem
backblech heraus freundin der mutter
sagt ja wenn man mein gesicht der muskel
wird das ist gut wenn man jetzt haben
wir nicht man hört man jetzt nicht danke
ich glaube die pizza wird mir so gut
schmecken ich habe auch so geile zutaten
gedrehten zum glück habe ich kein apfel
oder frikadellen macht schießt bay bot
er richtig gut wird jetzt gar nicht mehr
lange drum rum lagern und schwarze
machen wenn wir jetzt einfach die ganze
sache noch mal drauf sondern hat
kardashian hin
das ist so eine richtige hast du musst
du so einen richtig geilen abend für die
firma überlegen wie solar romantiker aus
dass wir die geile da ist es einfach da
ich habe danach fällt auf jeden fall
eine kleine scheibchen geschnitten und
legt die hier einfach so zwischendurch
ein bisschen drauf das sieht sehr gut
aus aber also sieht schön aus durch die
firma aber wenn man dann schritt
zurückgeht das soll das aber hierauf
stylo angesehen das ist meine pizza sie
sieht echt nicht so beschissen aus aber
ich glaube egal macht meinen linken
wasser ein bisschen thunfisch aus der
can can tun das ist der thuner alles
klar
ich will dass die pizza lecker wird ich
wollte dass meine extra beschissen
werden eine rolex-uhr dann aber weißt du
wo ich meine rolex an hatte in meinem
neuen tik tok video dass da ich heiße
laser lokal halt die fresse dollar
bekommt er meist drauf hier vorne
das ding jetzt deine pizza sieht halt
komplett unterschiedlich auch zu meiner
weile zufolge frikadellen und wetter und
eine summe jetzt doch um diesen trend
auch noch gut aussehen sind ich damit
welch ein bisschen sparsamer umgehen
also nicht ganz so viel und jetzt nützen
reinpacken ja jetzt durch rein weil die
mario kommt am ende bei mir drauf weil
ich noch mal so im backofen ist keine
gute idee
das heißt wir warten jetzt ein paar
minuten sind wieder drei solchen später
fertig zu geben tschuldigung richtig
geil
es ist halt so bei max muss mit ihm
einen esel noch drauf deswegen das war
so schön kuppelt die pizza an
also das was man sagen ich unfassbar
geil aus meine nicht aber da ist mario
da
okay ich mache das so zu spotlight welch
ein ganz besonderer spitzenkoch daran
mario und pizza gehören nicht zusammen
das sollte man eigentlich nicht machen
er ist ein kumpel von mir mal ist jetzt
mit sauce hollandaise youtube und fisch
das habe ich auch geguckt
dann wollen wir uns mal ein schönes
stückchen wo alles dabei ist so eine
delikatesse
ich habe ein bisschen halt weg ich weiß
jetzt wie mario hat allerdings du hier
ein stück vor der ok so das ist jetzt
natürlich einfach
[Musik]
also ich habe jetzt ein stück sind
vegetarische frikadelle dann ein
bisschen apfel hier nämlich noch die
michael wurst und hier dann bist du ein
abkommen mit den heißen strand auf den
abpfiff vor allem sonst ist eigentlich
auch alles geil gut oder wie was folgt
als auch weil es schmeckt wirklich der
abwehr hat für das komplette ihren platz
wie schmeckt wirklich wieso eine pizza
die wie ich schon gesagt habe die man
irgendwie mit zwölf jahren auf dem
kindergeburtstag sich gebacken hatten
geil aber aber dies prüfen die ok ich
hab' ich habe drei kinder ist das hier
die computer sind endliche drei kinder
von vier frauen
so ist das bei mir in der broicher
kommen doch so herr vom jupiter von den
blauen bergen im blauen haus wohne ich
da ja freunde versteht ihr gefallen hat
das gern einen daumenbruch unter dem
video hier da schreibt uns gerne und in
die kommentare welche zutaten wie
eventuell bei einem teil 2 benutzen
sollen max ist aber schreiber verlinkt
haben ein video aufgenommen mit dieser
wunderschönen wohl hier die ein
unsichtbar macht tim borowski
[Musik]